welcome to this video here we go that's
a rematch against mr. hung gasps key so
let's see we go we get this this opening
yet Queens gambit accepted check check
where I really have no good line I want
to go a form 3 a 4 but an e for a form
not a form but I have to admit that I
never got around to really study it and
in any kind of detail and um yeah so
this is why I'm playing this quite them
quite boring line with G take c-5m it's
not very exciting I have to admit
white sometimes gets a little something
but it's really only for the guys with
super technical play and I normally
never get anywhere so what do I do a
three or something it looks very equal
yeah q jos has been a problem in my
repertoire I never really looked at
something in in any kind of detail so
yeah if sex f6e 5 is an idea I can try
to trade off this this pesky night down
active peace let's get rid of that
yeah just quite equal now he can go if
I've Bishop f7 with no problem
whatsoever yeah maybe me it's before an
idea before we push them back to a seven
with the bishop probably but there's
nothing really great them Knight a5 yeah
but we also have to go there Group D 296
check snow big move but you can take on
a 5 which is just completely equal maybe
95 for being a bit ambitious it's just
an idea I could backfire and maybe you
can go 95 try hoping for F for group
texty too but I'm not going to play that
now retreating Jack can not really lead
to anything check in your zone what can
you do it's just equal yeah next time I
should play some other line even if i
don't know the line it's just completely
that's just really really boring this
game I've won some with this line it's
not like it's it's it's completely never
ever winning a game but it's yeah it
tends to look look like this game where
nothing ever is happening okay what do i
do him any way forward probably not
they're just there's nothing happening I
won't won't pretend there is something
there isn't
I'm just a little bit ahead on the clock
this is the dream position for whiter
for mr. vegas yeah shuffling around
completely without any purpose and
trying to win on time but yeah I'm just
continuing a little bit maybe something
is happening after all ok so if for and
then look see one look see one
immediately I met he might go back that
would be eight yeah okay all right yeah
he's right those two bishops they are
hanging mmm that was bad that was bad
I'm not sure that it's a big issue but
ok let's get this out of the picture
Bishop g2 King takes rook to e3 Roxy six
is ok for what I think I have gone to
play
boom yeah I didn't play that well what
do you two he's getting ty he's giving
getting time pressure time pressure on
what he's doing I can get very dangerous
against the right player check I thought
that not really Scott look b3 them
he always has rugby 3
I don't have an ideal defensive
formation down on the on the King side
ok now i will get this traded at least
have three years i guess trading this is
basically always a good them draw after
a change drawer there you can try of
course gentlemen but he's got very
little time check and it really is it
wrong check mmm so if I'm going up there
suka here sweetie no problem check check
I can go to G fireman shouldn't a time
or you should never load that one
there are stupid defense stupid defense
check check check draw chafford check he
really wants to try to win this and
maybe I really played it bad bad enough
that it's free justified okay so I'm
probably have to cut him Jack Crawford
and what is your idea you want to win
this on time now what Jack game what a
weird way to play yeah I just wanted to
be fair they're offering the draw when I
was ahead on time I didn't want to be a
pest them I know yeah I really played
that badly out of this I was a bit
frustrated with his opening when nothing
happens check but yeah player 2 to relax
them got myself into trouble with those
unprotected bishops there was a bad idea
ready even this is a bad idea can you
know there's nothing going on there we
should f3 or something and then just um
just do do nothing much oh yeah let God
that God ugly we should be two other
exceptionally bad idea okay so check
this is this yeah I problem is also that
that this isn't a completely
comfortable end game okay it got
comfortable this is this is just a
shepherd I played I played in a bad way
here let's check that what did I do
wrong look here check maybe I shouldn't
have given the checks them check it
should be ok basically check check their
check yeah what am I going to whatever
I'm not going back here it's just very
stupid this is just wrong it's just a
draw yeah just a draw it was very it was
an idiotic decision check no no I really
have to have to struggle badly them
kinky five might be near there a wind
snow for black shiny sure about that
check me this is a drawing Chabot I'm
still not concur cellist now that set is
it wrong but yeah there was there was a
bad game right I shouldn't really play
this line again even if I don't know
anything else really well this is just
too boring yeah I'm sorry for that
thanks for watching though